i've been talking a lot on the programme
about the planned unlocking for
tomorrow hearing about the risks the the
balance of risks
and of course we'll be able to socialize
indoors with up to six people
should the changes tomorrow go ahead or
should they be delayed
well i've just been listening to the
scientists on your show there
sophie and they're they're they're they
they seem very clear don't they
that the easing the restrictions
tomorrow is the right thing to do
we needn't be alarmed enough yet
to uh to reconsider that although the
question about what happens
in june remains now the problem for me
is why has uh the road out of the
lockdown become
so much more uncertain that it looks
just a few
weeks ago and the answer to that is the
prime minister
is not always following the science
in the way that he ought to be doing it
was just a
couple of a few weeks ago i was on your
show and we were discussing
the prime minister's plans to visit
india to speak to the indian prime
minister narendra
modi and as a result of that pakistan
and bangladesh
had been put on the red list but india
had not
and it didn't go on the red list until
three or three weeks after those other
two countries
although the virus was running out of
control in the whole
of the subcontinent now during that
three-week period
20 000 passengers came back from india
to the uk and the indian variant
appears to have got into the country
because of that if the government was
prioritizing the protection of the
borders we may not even have this
level of uncertainty now now we have to
deal with it now we're trying to
understand
whether this new variant is more
contagious or not
but frankly we shouldn't even be in this
position if the government was
protecting and securing the borders in
the way that they ought to do
and i understand the debates about
whether or not the government should
have acted sooner uh to try and um
tackle the individual on borders but
just want to go back to the question
about what happens
tomorrow because she was saying that the
scientists were quite clear
my sense is they're not totally clear on
whether
it should go ahead tomorrow uh mark
walpole talking about
um you know the risks matt hancock
saying there's going to be a problem
uh if actually um it is 50
more transmissible if the unlocking goes
ahead we've got this sage advice of
course
uh saying that um if the individual is
up to more
50 more transmissible uh then that
actually could lead
the unlocking tomorrow could actually
lead to a resurgence in cases and
hospitalizations that equals or even
exceeds the previous peaks
so is the science really clear i'm not
sure it is
well we we don't know the answer to some
of the questions you're posing there
sophie and the
the india variant seems to be more
prevalent in certain parts of the
country
at the moment than uh than elsewhere and
this is always going to be
a balance of risks isn't it the risk of
keeping the lock down
longer and all of the damage that that's
doing to the economy and lives and
livelihoods
and the risks in the risks and opening
up now we're in a slightly riskier
situation than we should have been
because of missteps the government's
taken over protecting the borders but
i think right now the the judgment to
take is that we should go ahead with the
lockdown uh easing of the lockdown
tomorrow keep a very close eye on what
developments are so that we can
uh review whether the planned opening
later in uh in june is the right thing
to do but
short term we need to make sure that the
measures are
in place to contain the variant or
the the virus in those areas where it
seems to be uh gaining more of a
foothold and that means looking at
contact tracing and making that work far
better than it has previously
people who have been self-isolating at
home we understand only three and a
hundred
have been contacted that's not
acceptable but that system has to work
far better
than that and the the other core issue
that i also heard your your previous
guests
uh refer to excuse me is uh
self-isolation payments
if people are afraid they will lose um
income
by self-isolating because they're on low
pay or insecure work
then we run the risk that they won't be
able to afford to do it and therefore
people will be moving around in society
and potentially transmitting
the virus we have to fix self-isolation
payments and we have to get contact
tracing
working far better than currently if
we're going to keep a grip on this
variant
whether it's more contagious or not okay
so
labor's positioned that tomorrow's
unlocking should go ahead
the one in june should be kept under
review
if the data suggests that actually the
transmissibility is what
some of the scientists fear then should
we be prepared to reverse the changes
coming in tomorrow
we always have to be prepared to do that
don't we if the science
tells us that the situation is no longer
safe and we're heading towards
uh another more serious and prolonged
lockdown then we're in trouble now
the previous uh decisions that the
government
you know dodged really like the um the
uh
the circuit breaker that sage was
recommending to the government back in
september october last year because the
government didn't do that
we ended up with a much higher rate of
infection infections over christmas and
into the new year
and a rate of deaths that really could
have been avoided
had the government acted earlier none of
us want to be in that position again so
if the science is telling us
that this variant is more infectious
than than it may well be at the moment
and of course
that must always be kept under review
because that's the way that we prevent
our more severe and prolonged lockdown
later in the year
should we be prepared to impose
restrictions regionally or locally
in hot spot areas or should we always be
looking
for national a national picture
well i mean my view is the the regional
tears didn't really work very well last
time they very quickly
broke down because people move around i
think it you know the lesson from that
for me is it's best if we move together
uh if we move together as one country
but there are things the government
should be doing in the meantime i think
particularly what i was saying about
contact tracing self-isolation payments
those are there if you talk talk to
local leaders regional mayors
council leaders public health directors
they tell you
that these are the things the government
needs to focus on they have not been
working well enough up until now
it's urgent that the government fixes
them if we're going to contain the virus
without running the risk of a
a longer more prolonged lockdown how are
you going to act tomorrow
mark walpole told me that we should be
hugging cautiously matt hancock said
he's going to be hugging people outside
what's your what's your policy
i mean we need people to behave with you
know as
much uh restraint as they can i'd be
going into parliament tomorrow so i
suspect
i won't be hugging very many people at
all but you know
i i think we can trust the good the good
judgment of uh
of people we know this variant is out
there we know this is this thing isn't
it isn't over yet the british people
have behaved with extraordinary
uh self-restraint over over recent
months all of us are desperate to get
out there and get back to our lives as
as they used to be but we have a little
further to go into at that point
unfortunately sorry to hear that if
you're being cautious of your hugging
there's not many parliamentarians that
are going to make the cut there
now i want to talk a little bit about
labor
uh it's been a difficult few weeks for
the labour party i'm sure you'll
admit a lot of criticism that people
just don't know what labour under
kirsten
stands for and it feels as if the you
know the conservative party messaging is
kind of drilled into all of our brains
get brexit done leveling up
um you know building that better and if
i'm being honest i was trying to
remember
what labour's slogan was going into
may's elections
and i actually couldn't remember it what
was it
secure the economy and protect the nhs
was the the core
of the messaging that we were going into
those elections with but you know
the point you make is um is right uh
since the the election earthquake for us
of december 2019
labour's clearly had an electoral
mountain to climb no one's made any
bones about that i haven't uh secured
stammer certainly
hasn't and in between here being elected
just over a year ago in the elections we
just had
we've had the lockdown so um as leader
of the labour party kier has still not
been
able to get out there and shake a real
voter's hand or give a speech in front
of a live audience and with the country
necessarily and understandably
focused on the crisis and how we get get
out of it
it's been very difficult to find the
space to start talking about a forward
offer
from the labour party i mean despite all
of that despite
the huge disappointment of the hartley
pool result
if you look at the results across the
whole country they were
much more mixed than they looked the
morning after
hartley pool we were picking up um
council seats in
uh in sussex in hertfordshire we won 11
of the 13
uh mayoral elections across it was good
it was mixed i'm not going to pretend it
was good i absolutely admit we've got
we've got we've got a mountain to climb
but it was a bit more mixed and
if we have a mountain to climb which is
how we described it uh
since the general election in 2019 then
last week
we had halved the tory lead compared to
the general election that's progress but
it's not enough because we need to
overhaul
the conservatives if we're going to win
the next general election that was never
going to be done in one year no one ever
pretended it could be done
uh in a single year and particularly
given the circumstances of the pandemic
it's been very difficult for a party to
come out um
and project uh a set of proposals for
the future
as we come out of the lockdown as
politics starts to normalize and we face
uh
face the future again without the uh the
domination
of the pandemic uh in all of our minds
that is when
labour can start to make its future
offer to the country
and the shadow chancellor the newly
appointed shadow
chancellor rachel reeves has already
started doing that this week
talking about work talking about the the
family
talking about the importance of place
and community to people we will start to
flesh out a series of proposals around
that
and we'll do it by talking to
reconnecting with
and listening to the country so that the
labour party's
priorities reflect the concerns and
priorities of the british people perhaps
in a way that they haven't done in
recent years
she's got to be careful talk about work
that's angelo rainer's brief isn't it
it's the idea the agenda that we will be
developing will be for the whole
of the labour party to talk about
together
and angela's a close friend of mine
she's a fantastic communicator she's got
a big role to play in all of this of
course
i take your point about the difficulties
projecting
your offer during a pandemic but the
issue that people have is
have you actually got an offer to
project you know
secure our economy protect our nhs the
conservatives could say
exactly that thing it feels that people
don't actually know what the big vision
is i mean you're close to kids start
well
what is it what is the big vision the
revolution that many people want
i i genuinely don't think it's right for
me to just sit here
uh and describe to you what the outcome
of a process of engagement with the
british people over the next few months
is going to be
if it's a genuine engagement and we have
to be out there and listening but if
we're just
doing you've been doing that for 18
months you haven't just suddenly
kissed time hasn't just suddenly come
into power some people would say that
what i'm asking you for i'm giving you a
platform
to speak to our viewers to speak to
people of the uk about what the big
vision is and you've actually ducked it
isn't that exactly the issue let's take
work
let's take work let's take work as one
uh
as one as one issue we know that one of
the problems
is that there have not been enough good
new secure jobs
in every single part of the country so
that every
place every town every city every county
can be the best place to grow up the
best place to grow old and the best
place to live and to work that
investment hasn't
been coming in so we've seen the good
old manufacturing jobs replaced by
low paid insecure jobs in the gig
economy and that isn't what people need
to see
now we have to work out how we are going
to work with the different regions to
bring in the investment
to sustain the good jobs of the future
that can give everybody the security
they need that their work that they can
get a job in their locality that is
going to see them and their families
through the future now one of the key
ways of doing that is through devolution
it's through opening up power so all the
decisions aren't taken
uh in in in whitehall but many more
decisions taken
in localities uh by people who
understand how their localities work
better
now the government has been trailing for
the last two years
a devolution bill that was set up their
proposals for that
we got the queen's speech just um just
last week
no sign of the devolution bill they
dropped it and the reason i think
they've dropped it
is because labour won 11 of the 13 metro
mayoral
elections the conservatives are
frightened that when people see labour
in power they like it
so they've dropped their plans for
devolution that is one of the key ways
that we get the investment in
and the infrastructure in to bring in
the good jobs of the future and the
conservatives are refusing to do it so
there's one area
where i think labour can start to hammer
them very very hard as we emerge from
the pandemic